-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with Michelle Pfeiffer
[ Cheering and applause ]
and we
are about to go head-to-head
in a new game called
Sniff Cup Flip Cup.
[ Cheering ]
-♪ Sniff Cup ♪
♪ Flip Cup ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
Now, this is just like
the drinking game Flip Cup,
but with an extra challenge.
Each of these red SOLO cups
contains a different scent.
It could be any of the scents
on the screen behind us.
First, you flip the cup,
then you try to guess the scent.
If you guess right,
you keep going.
If you guess wrong,
you keep flipping.
The first person to get
through all their cups wins.
Michelle, are you ready
for this?
-If you guess wrong,
you keep flipping.
-Yes, that's correct.
-Then what happens?
-Then you got to keep flipping.
Then, once you flip it over,
then you get to sniff again,
try again.
-Okay, alright.
-Have you done this before?
-I was practicing a little.
-Yeah, okay, here we go.
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
I've never played this.
Okay, here we go.
3, 2, 1, good luck.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Mellow funk plays ]
-Coconut.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Coconut!
[ Laughter ]
-Aah!
Aah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Uh, vanilla.
No.
-Yeah.
-No, orange!
[ Buzzer ]
You got to flip!
-No!
-No, well, you didn't say
anything yet.
Oh, I go again.
Coconut?
No, bubble gum, bubble gum!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-It doesn't smell,
so, what do I do now?
-You say, "Bubble gum."
-Bubble gum.
-That's right, go.
-Okay.
-Go to the third one.
[ Laughter ]
-It doesn't smell
like bubble gum.
-It doesn't, really.
Aah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Bacon!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ooh!
-Aah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's a hard one.
Aah!
Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
Are you waiting for me?
Are you embarrassing me?
What are you doing?
I want to quit!
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know what it is!
Is it a Henry rose fragrance?
-Oh, no, you know,
it's something.
Uh, wait.
Wait, what is it?
Something -- Coffee!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's weak!
Come on.
-Aah!
No! No!
-Uh --
-Henry Rose fragrance?
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
♪♪
I'm a good winner.
-I got to give it to you --
-I'm a good winner.
-Yeah, yeah, you're really --
I am not a sore winner.
Michelle Pfeiffer, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Her fragrance line --
Her fragrance line,
Henry Rose, is awesome.
It's available at henryrose.com.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Lil Rel Howery, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]